hello and welcome back to bloodline the
taxonomy of fear where we examine what
if anything makes a movie scary I am
Jordan crochet Olaf and I am j david and
today we'll be looking at asian horror
in yamla Ron uses the road which is from
the Philippines my people made a scary
movie this movie is told in three parts
the first part is an ill-fated joy ride
down a haunted road the second part is
the story about how that road became
haunted and the third part is the origin
story of the villain so here we go
number one obscured faces there's this
long-standing tradition in asian horror
films where the the face of this evil
figure is veiled and a hat or a shawl or
something I grew up with the art typical
scary image of the Asian girl with a
hair combed in front of her face this
movie had obscured faces all over the
place any ghosts or any person that was
killed had the obscured face second
criteria use of children as victims now
this is something that seems pretty
taboo for the most part in the United
States you know typically the children
are you know if they're in a scary movie
they're kind of the doers of evil
Village of the Damned children of the
corn insidious these are all examples of
kids terrorizing the adults around them
in this movie in an Asian fields in
general yeah that rules out the window
yeah the kids
so finally the third one is a melodrama
yeah philippine cinema owes a lot to the
telenovela you name the family drama
unwanted pregnancies sorted love affairs
stealing money from the family
plantation okay I got a little personal
there I apologize walking back that
scenario Filipinos will overact the hell
out of that scene and I have to admit I
was a little disappointed that there was
some natural acting in this movie haha
they played a little too straight man in
the road for Jay I'm gonna go with two
hours because that first 30 minutes I
was screaming repeatedly every time the
apparition came on it was the audible
jump back yeah I would say one hour
because I was really obsessed with how
beautiful everybody was in this movie it
was like a Filipino shampoo commercial
except with like murder and people
getting run over it was super hot number
one for me before anything else stick
together especially if you're like seven
years old and number two if it's you man
versus machine you're being chased by a
car and your choices are run down an
unobstructed road or run into a thick
forest pick the thick forest we threw
the tree and obviously the trees that's
exactly right and finally at number
three murder suicide is not the best
option to get out of a bad marriage my
pick is the host a free movie that came
out in 2006 the opening scene where the
monks are a text the park is like a
master class and how to shoot a scary
scene in broad daylight it's brilliant
I'm gonna recommend from 2002 the
original The Grudge called Duan and this
the road put me in a really good creepy
kid mood and that will come in spades if
you check this movie out
that's it for this week's episode of
bloodline email us at bloodline at wired
com with questions comments concerns
we'd like to hear from you and as we
like to say here at bloodline this is
the movie